it's been three months since anastasia
fled her life in kharkiv it was a
journey that took days a journey filled
with anguish a journey that felt endless
along the way she received a call from
her father who stayed behind to fight
a call she won't forget
after maybe three minutes of yelling
that he's alive he told me that
the bomb landed in that in his office
when he was and he his soldiers also
the bomb landed
and ceiling fell down on my dad
um
i
i was scared but because of war i lost
my feelings
and i feel nothing
anastasia's battle wounds can't be seen
but she feels them every day
not feeling something is not good
it's extremely bad
i have trauma definitely because of my
dad i'm constantly worried about him
rend has seen firsthand how devastating
the situation is she fears what will
happen without intervention
so if we don't have more support i think
it's a life or death situation for many
ukrainians for two reasons firstly
because they may want to go back to
ukraine and risk their lives doing that
and second because they may actually end
up
unfortunately not getting the support
that they need over here
taking their own lives
for now getting this support involves
waiting times the government says local
authorities will be key in providing
trauma counselling but for many like
anastasia if help isn't quick enough it
could become difficult for the scars to
heal aisha hits sky news